well good morning everybody I want to
welcome you to the ale tech forum and
Morrison Foerster San Francisco offices
it's real pleasure to see everybody and
it's an honor for us to host the event
this year or excited and hope that the
program is both substantive and adds
value that way and as helpful as well as
providing hopefully some fruitful
networking opportunities for funding
strategic or other purposes my name is
Chuck Comey I'm a partner here at
Morrison Foerster I'm silliman class of
eighty-four where as an English major we
mofo as we like to call ourselves are
yeah we've actually trademarked that so
we're the only I think honestly speaking
were the only emerging company law firm
with a truly global platform and so at a
time when I think san francisco and the
bay area is one of the crossroads of
venture capital as it's really
internationalized and has come full
circle back to the bay area where it
started its it's a really great time to
be with you all and to be with victor
are our conference organizer we we work
a lot with emerging companies like
atheer which does augmented reality
treasure data automated data collection
zoosk and other companies one of the
things that really distinguishes us
though is our focus on social
entrepreneurship and that efforts been
led by our partners Sue's McCormick who
was recognized by the Financial Times as
the most innovative north american
lawyer of the year 2015 for her work in
the social and impact investing area she
helped california enact its legislation
for social purpose corporations we work
with clients like imprint capital and
its impact investing
goldman sachs and other impact investors
as well revolution foods in Oakland is
another one of our clients on the
Investor side and strategics and again
this is a time when foreign strategics
are very active we work with firms like
Ching hai Yuna group which is one of the
most prolific investors in US technology
companies and and we see this as a
continuing very fruitful vein including
for new companies let me offer to theses
for you to refute or affirm during the
course of today's discussion we all know
that SecureWorks is traded off in the
IPO aftermarket we all know the
statistics for q1 in terms of venture
investing down by twenty-five percent or
more q1 to the last quarter of 2014 Asia
investments down by a third so my first
thesis is winter is coming and you
better dress warmly but my second thesis
is maybe it's not all that cold out
after all because we see in our practice
and Victor and I were talking
notwithstanding the the u.s. VC firms
perhaps hunkering down there a careful
group there's all flavors of other kinds
of money that are now available for
companies like yours and a lot of the
opportunity I think is that same natural
synergy that exists between centers of
innovation whether they're in Silicon
Valley or anywhere else in our country
and pools of capital that for example in
China as domestic growth moderates are
increasingly looking for opportunities
not just at the strategic stage or the
M&A stage but at the angel stage so all
flavors of funds as I'm sure you're
aware are not just strategics like
Tencent which has a big office across
from City Hall in downtown
auto they're kicking the tires they're
looking around and so it's exciting to
see those kinds of opportunities so you
can decide what you think about that but
with that I'd like to turn it over to
Victor to usher in the rest of this
morning's agenda again we hope the time
is fruitful and helpful for you and
thanks again for giving us the
opportunity to sponsor hi everyone i'm
victor wong one of the co-organizers of
yale tech which obviously many of you
have heard of since you're your eyes are
here I wanted to start off by
acknowledging some of the key
co-organizers that made this event
possible not just this particular
conference but also many of the events
that i know a lot of you guys enjoy
that's produced for the eotech community
so i wanted to acknowledge stand up if
you guys are already here if you woke up
this morning i'm going to interest
daniel y le he's back in the corner as
well as Simon I think he's someone
where's Simon he's definitely here all
right Holly westerhof as well Matt King
Mickey dog she's from aya has also been
instrumental making this possible Greg
how sure he's running the New York group
John a ohh and rich little Hill didn't
get up this what quite early enough all
right anna-lena who I don't know
couldn't make it out here but has also
been instrumental organizing so I also
wanted to thank a few key sponsors who
made this whole event possible instacart
which hosted last night's pre-conference
happy hour which I know many of you were
able to attend for those who are
unfamiliar with instacart it's a grocery
delivery service on demand to your very
home obviously mofo who's been generous
in providing the space and I wanted to
welcome real briefly McLarty associates
who's been also a very key supporter of
Yale tech is Elliot available to just
say a few words
thanks Victor and thanks mofo for
hosting I've got to rewire what that
phrase means in my brain so it will give
me a second M some clarity associates is
a global government relations firm we
help primarily US multinationals
startups expanded to China Saudi Africa
Europe Mexico Aladdin etc we are about
50 former ambassadors we have an office
in Beijing and we take a sort of more
diplomatic approach to engagement with
government stakeholders and we also
advise a series of family offices
international family offices on
investing in Silicon Valley so I look
forward to to chatting with y'all thanks
again thanks so I just want to offer a
few remarks opening up this conference
is our third annual conference for the
Yale tech community the theme this
so the theme today is changing the face
of tech and that was a very deliberate
theme that we wanted to bring this year
when i started yelled tech in 2011 to
bring together the growing Yale tech
community I wanted to highlight
obviously Yale as a growing leader in
the technology space but for a industry
that's obviously all about disruption
and change some things about the tech
industry hasn't changed very much or has
progressed at a very glacial pace so
this year's theme particular wanted to
control attention to where we have made
progress and I think we're Yale and its
leaders have I think been exemplary in
some areas but in the last year you know
we've seen a lot of controversies close
to here and close to Yale things like
Ellen Pao obviously here in Silicon
Valley back at yo obviously a lot of
people here probably are still talking
about Calhoun and some of the things are
going on there you know also back here a
lot of the numbers and statistics around
diversity released by the big companies
this year have been pretty shocking and
I think I've started a good dialogue
when I started my company which is a
thunder recently rebranded from paper G
we were just moved out to San Francisco
and I remember when we were faced with a
decision as a 20-person company we had
hired actually our first expected mother
actually as an executive in our company
and you know for a company that was
growing we had you know as you imagine
for tech company a lot of men not many
women executives and it was kind of a
key moment for us actually where we
realized we had a moment in time to kind
of shape the sort of company that we
want it to be and so when faced kind of
with this new situation I remember we
actually had this interesting moment
that we tried to figure out what was
going to be our maternity or paternity
policy how we were we going to handle
that and what we ended up doing actually
was conducting what ended up becoming
the industry's largest survey of
venture-backed companies and public tech
companies of their maternity and
paternity policy and that
allowed us to figure out what would be a
generous and supportive policy in our
company environment but will realize
that it was not just about our company
obviously and just helping us shape our
decision but that data set that we
accumulated it could be useful for
everyone and so we ended up publishing
that that data publicly and our findings
around different tech companies at
different stages we're doing about this
and that ended up I think heavily
influencing even to this day a lot of
companies policies in terms of what
they've implemented and how generous
that they've been now I think growing at
a growing rate to their employees and so
from this experience you know I realized
that change really does start with each
and every one of us we're all in a
position to influence the world to be
what we want it to be and that we have
to make a conscious decision to take
action it doesn't just happen overnight
change happens because of the leaders
that you're going to hear from today so
I hope today these these speakers and
these leaders are going to inspire you
to be leaders in your own company and
drive the change that you want to see so
thank you all for coming today